Alright. This is pretty cool, Sam. We've got all these charts, and let me put
them in our dashboard. And then what else could we do for a music festival?
>> Well, I mean, there are so many different chart types, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Like we haven't used pie chart yet.
>> You could probably have a distribution
of all the different types of music.
>> Mm-hm.
>> That were playing at the festival.
>> Maybe a percentage of how may are Bossa nova?
>> Right.
[LAUGH]
>>
>> I don't even know who Bossa nova is.
>> I know.
>> Well maybe we like I would like
to know, for the different stages, who's racking up
the most maintenance tickets, cause you know maybe
they need to get their act together or something.
>> Yeah, and I mean that's another pie chart we could make. Is distribution
of priority of tickets. Like how many are marked as high priority versus low?
>> Right, well let's let's make one.
>> Okay.